let's take you to the US where President
Joe Biden is meeting India's prime
minister Narendra Modi and they have
just begun the press conference let's
listen in and to address the joint
session for Congress
it's a testament to the strong and
enduring and thoroughly bipartisan
support that exists all across the
United States for the friendship and
partnership with Union in the United
States that the they're anxiously
waiting to hear you up on Capitol Hill
partnership that is among the most
consequential in the world that is
stronger closer and more Dynamic than
any time in history
Mr Prime Minister we've met many times
over the past few years most recently in
Hiroshima at the G7 Summit and each time
I was struck by our ability to find new
areas of cooperation
together we're unlocking the shared
future of what I believe to be unlimited
potential
and with this visit we're demonstrating
once more how Indian United States are
collaborating on nearly every human
endeavor and delivering progress across
the board
from designing new ways to diagnose and
treat illnesses
like cancer and diabetes to
collaborating on human space flight
including sending an Indian astronaut
through the International Space Station
in 2024
through accelerating a global clean
energy transition and tackling climate
climate crisis we face
to harnessing our shared expertise on
critical and emerging Technologies by
Quantum Computing and artificial
intelligence to ensuring they are not
used as tools of misinformation and
oppression we are doubling down on our
cooperation to secure our semic
conductors our semiconductor Supply
chains advancing open Rand
telecommunications Networks and growing
our major defense partnership with a
more joint exercises more cooperation
between our defense Industries and more
consultation and coordination across all
domains our economic relationship is
booming
trade between our countries is almost
doubled over the past decade to more
than 191 billion dollars
supporting tens of thousands of good
jobs in both India and the United States
add to that one million American jobs
across 44 States will be supported by
the purchase of more than 200 more than
200 American made Boeing aircraft
by that air Indians announcing earlier
this year
and with this visit Indian firms are
announcing more than two billion dollars
more than two billion dollars in new
investments in manufacturing solar in in
Colorado Steel in Ohio and optic fiber
in South Carolina and much more
further proof that America's
manufacturing is back
we're expanding educational exchanges
for our students building on the record
000 student visas for Indians to study
in the United States we issued last year
and opening new consulates that's going
to make it easier for our people to
travel work and collaborate together
on the issues that matter most and that
will Define the future our nation's look
to one another including on critical
Regional and Global issues
and today we also talked about our
shared efforts to mitigate
humanitarian tragedies Unleashed by
Russia's brutal war in Ukraine and to
defend the core principles of the U.N
Charter sovereignty and territorial
integrity
we discussed our work through the quad
and how India and the United States
together with Australia and Japan can
ensure the vital indo-pacific region
remains free open prosperous and secure
through our new I2 YouTube ground
grouping with Israel in the UAE we're
building Regional connections to the
Middle East inspiring science-based
Solutions and the global challenges like
food security and clean energy and this
year under India's leadership of the G20
we're putting sustainable development at
the center of the agenda
we're delivering meaningful action on
low and middle income Nations including
multilateral Development Bank reform
debt relief and building resilient and
Equitable Health Systems
the bottom line is simple
we want people everywhere to have the
opportunity to live in dignity
and let me be close with this Indians
and Americans are both peoples who
innovate and create
turn obstacles and opportunities who
find strength in community and family
and her cherished freedom and celebrate
the democratic values of universal human
rights which face challenges around the
world and each and in each of our
countries but which remained so vital to
the success of each of our Nations
press Freedom religious freedom
tolerance diversity
India now has the most populous
countries now the most populous country
in the world
it's a democracy
we understand that it is has it it is
the Brilliance and the backbone of our
people as diverse and talents and
traditions that make us strong as a
nation it's democracies that do that we
see that so clearly here in the United
States where a Vibrant indian-american
Community of more than four million
strong contributes every single day to
the writing of the future of our nation
Indian Americans of every background and
Faith representing the full diversity of
India are pursuing their American Dream
while maintaining deep connections for
their Indian Heritage and Families
that that makes us all stronger that is
a Cornerstone of this essential
partnership between India and the United
States and that is why I know the
friendship between our Nations is only
going to grow as we Face the future
together Mr Prime Minister the floor is
yours
foreign
[Applause]
friends from the media
namaskar
first of all I thank President Biden for
his warm words and for his positive
views on India America relations
friends
today is a day that has
special importance in the history of
India America relations our discussions
today and the important decisions we
have taken have added
a new chapter to our comprehensive and a
global strategic partnership
they have given it a new Direction and a
new energy friends
a trade and investment partnership
between India and America is important
not only for our two countries but for
the global economy as well
today
America is India's biggest trade partner
we have decided
to resolve long pending trade related
issues
and make a new beginning
the initiative for critical and emerging
Technologies iset has emerged as an
important framework for our technical
cooperation
by
increasing our cooperation in fields
such as artificial intelligence
semiconductor space Quantum and Telecom
we are creating a strong and futuristic
partnership
the decision taken by American companies
such as Micron Google and Applied
Materials to invest in India
[Music]
symbolizes this futuristic partnership
during this journey
I also had the opportunity to meet some
other American CEOs and in my
discussions with them I could feel their
enthusiasm and their positive views
about India we both agree
that to make a strategic technology
partnership meaningful
it is very important that governments
businesses and academic institutions
come together
in order to implement India and
America's shared Vision on clean energy
transition we have taken several
important initiatives
these cover areas such as green hydrogen
wind energy
battery storage and carbon capture
we have also decided that in the midst
of Global uncertainties India and
America will as trusted Partners create
reliable secure and resilient Global
Supply chains
and value chains as well
the close defense cooperation between
India and America
symbolizes a mutual trust and shared
strategic priorities
moving away from the old buyer seller
relationship we had earlier we have
transitioned today to a relationship
involving transfer of technology
co-development and co-production
the decision taken by General Electric
to
manufacture engines in India through
transfer of technology is a landmark
agreement
this also opens up new job opportunities
in both countries
this will give our defense cooperation a
new character in The Times to come
[Music]
the defense Industries and startups of
both countries are important Partners in
this cooperation bringing them together
is the key objective of our defense
industrial roadmap in the area of Space
Science and Technologies we have had
long-standing cooperation
by taking the decision to join the
Artemis Accords we have taken a big leap
forward in our space cooperation in fact
in short for India and America
partnership
even this
even the sky is not the limit
friends
the most important pillar of our
relations is our people-to-people ties
more than
four million people of Indian origin
today
makes significant contribution to the
progress of America in fact just this
morning the large number of Indians that
gathered at the White House
demonstrates that the Indian Americans
in fact are the real strength behind our
relations in order to further deepen
these relations we welcome
America's decision to open consulates in
Bengaluru and Ahmedabad
similarly
we will also open a new Indian Consulate
in Seattle friends in our meeting today
we discussed several Regional and Global
issues
peace and Security in the indo-pacific
is a common priority
we agree that the development and
success of this region is important for
the entire world
we shared our views to enhance
coordination with all countries in this
region along with our court partners
India and America stand shoulder to
shoulder in the fight against terrorism
and fundamentalism
we were in agreement that
concrete actions are needed in order to
end cross-border terrorism
the covet pandemic and the Ukraine
conflict have Afflicted the countries of
the global South in particular We
Believe
that in order to resolve these problems
it is absolutely imperative for all
countries to unite
from the very beginning of the events in
Ukraine India has laid emphasis on
resolution of dispute through dialogue
and diplomacy
we are completely ready to contribute in
any way we can to restore peace
under India's G20 presidency we are
laying emphasis on the spirit of one
Earth one family one future
we are lending a voice to the priorities
of the global South
I thank President Biden that he has
expressed support to my proposal of
giving the African Union full membership
of the G20 friends
the core philosophy of all of our
Collective efforts is to strengthen
democracy and Democratic Values and
Democratic order
two of the world's largest democracies
India and America can together make an
important contribution to Global Peace
stability and prosperity
I'm confident
that based on these values we will be
able to fulfill the expectations and
aspirations of not only the people of
our two countries but of the entire
world President Biden thank you for the
meaningful discussion today
this year
during the G20 Summit
we are looking forward to welcoming you
this is myself and all of India is
looking forward to welcoming you to
India and as president has said I do
have another engagement after this I
need to address the Congress so I do not
want to take any more time and I am
going to stop here for once again
President Biden thank you very much
well the Congress is actually waiting to
an anxiously way to hear you
told her two questioners Sabrina from
The Wall Street Journal and Kumar from
the uh Trust of India and uh Sabrina you
first
thank you Mr President I have a question
for the Prime Minister but first a
two-part question for you uh your
comments at a fundraiser this week
appear to be the first time in recent
memory that a sitting U.S president has
called a Chinese leader a dictator did
those comments about President XI
undermine or complicate the progress
your Administration has made in
maintaining a relationship with China
and secondly on India as you raise these
broader issues of Human Rights and
democracy what is your message to those
including some members of your own party
who say that your Administration is
overlooking a targeting of religious
minorities and Crackdown on dissent in
prime minister modi's country
answer your first question is no
oh
we're talking to our allies and and
partners around the world including
India
we let the uh
uh
the idea
of my
choosing and avoiding saying what I
think is the facts with regard to
relationship with India with uh China is
uh is just not uh something I'm going to
uh change very much
I think we I believe that and I've said
this for some time
that the hysteria about the relationship
with China is collapsing and moving et
cetera et cetera we had an incident that
caused some some confusion you might say
but president but the secretary blanken
had a great trip to China I expect to be
meeting with President XI sometime in
the future
the near term and uh I don't think it's
had any real consequence uh and what was
your second question
so as you raise these broader issues of
Human Rights and democracy what is your
message to those including some members
of your own party who believe that your
Administration is overlooking the
targeting of religious minorities and a
Crackdown on dissent in India
well look uh the Prime Minister and I
had a good discussion about democratic
values and uh and there's a there is the
uh that's the nature of our relationship
we're straightforward with each other
and uh and we respect each other one of
the fundamental reasons that I believe
the U.S China uh relationship is not in
the space it is in the U.S Indian
relationship is that there's an
overwhelming respect for each other
because we're both democracies
and uh it's a common Democratic
candidate character in both our
countries that and our people our
diversity our culture our open tolerant
robust debate and I believe uh that we
believe in the Dignity of every citizen
and it is an America's DNA and I believe
in India's DNA
that the whole world the whole world has
a stake in our success both of us in
maintaining our democracies makes us
appealing partners and enables us to uh
expand democratic institutions across
around the world and uh I believe this
and I still believe this
Mr Prime Minister India has long pride
in itself as the world's largest
democracy but there are many human
rights groups who say that your
government has discriminated against
religious minorities and sought to
silence its critics
as you stand here in the East room of
the White House where so many world
leaders have made commitments to
protecting democracy what steps are you
and your government willing to take to
improve the rights of Muslims and other
minorities in your country and to uphold
free speech
people don't say it indeed India is a
democracy
and as President Biden also mentioned
India
and America
both countries
democracy is in our DNA
the democracy is our spirit
democracy runs in our veins
we live democracy
and our ancestors have actually put
words to this concept and that is in the
form of our constitution our governments
has taken the basic principles of
democracy and on that basis our
constitution is made and the entire
country runs on that our Constitution
and our government we have always proved
that democracy can deliver and when I
say deliver this is regardless of cost
greed religion gender there's absolutely
no space for discrimination and when you
talk of democracy
there are no human values and there is
no Humanity
there are no human rights then it's not
a democracy and that is why when you say
democracy and you accept democracy
and when we live democracy then there is
absolutely no space for discrimination
and that is why India believes in moving
ahead with everybody we trust and with
everybody's efforts these are our
foundation principles which are the
basis of how we operate how we live our
lives in in India the benefits that are
provided by the government is accessible
to all whoever deserves those benefits
is available to everybody and that is
why in India's Democratic Values there
is absolutely no discrimination neither
on basis of cast read or age or any kind
of geographic location
Kumar yeah thanks a lot sir uh sir my
question is on the issue of climate
change both countries have spoken
strongly about the need to tackle the
climate change but there is a view
both I'm sorry both countries have
spoken about the challenge of climate
change but there is a view that
ambitious targets are set but
implementation is found often lacking
and there is also a criticism of lack of
technological transfer Financial
transfer from the developed countries to
the developing nations how do you both
leaders see the uh way ahead on this
pressing issue
well first of all I think it is the
existential threat to humanity climate
change it's the most serious problem we
face as human beings
we have to keep it below 1.5 degrees
Celsius
we've made enormous progress here in the
United States on dealing with this issue
by doing three things number one by
insisting that we move our every one of
our Industries into a position where
they can take advantage of cheaper and
more extensive and more available
renewable energy whether it's solar or
wind or hydrogen and green hydrogen
there's a whole range of things we've
been working on in addition to that we
find ourselves in a position that what
we've done is that we have significantly
reduced the for example I made a
commitment that we are going to make
sure that by 2030 30 percent of all our
land and sea and oceans were are in
conservation could not be developed
we're well on our way to doing that and
that's also absorbing carbon from the
air as a consequence of that because of
the conservation
we are in a position as well but we have
provided for significant increase in
funding for a whole range of issues but
not just for the United States but for
the rest of the world for example we're
working with the G7 to provide for
infrastructure work for commute for uh
dealing with global warming in the
continent of Africa an end goal of
building the largest solar project
moving ourselves to having Railway to go
all the way across the southern two
thirds the the from the Atlantic Ocean
to the to the Indian Ocean in Africa to
be able to transport and do it cheaper
and do it with less less how can I say
it less carbon emissions
we're trying to work with other
countries to maintain their maintain
their carbon sinks so they don't have to
develop them like we did in causing
pollution and we're trying to figure out
how to work out to pay them not to
develop certain areas like the Amazon
and Brazil but there's a lot of
Technology that's available that we're
sharing and we share with one another
we've learned how to do solar energy
which is considerably cheaper than it is
to for for fuel for fossil fuels the
same way dealing with not just solar but
dealing with uh Wind And so there's a
lot of technology that we've developed
and uh and we're well on our way I think
to meeting the commitment we made to uh
that we made in Paris and we're prepared
to share all of that with India that has
a desire to do the same
Excellency you said very rightly that as
far as India is concerned
environment the environment climate
these are
extremely important in our cultural
traditions for us the environment is an
article of faith
this is not just something that we need
to do for convenience we believe this
exploitation
we do not believe in the exploitation of
nature
in order for all of
creation to work
We Can Make nature but we cannot have
exploitation of Nature and we have
always believed this
and on the basis of these values we are
not only doing things for ourselves but
are taking some Global initiatives as
well uh you perhaps know that the G20
countries the promises they made in
Paris
of all the G20 countries India is the
only country that has fulfilled all the
promises it made at the G20 not just
that in the area of solar energy in
Glasgow
500. we had set ourselves the target to
achieve 500 gigawatts of renewable
energy
by 2030 we have set ourselves the target
to make Indian railways Net Zero and you
must understand the scale of Indian
railways when we talk about Indian
railways it means that every day the
entire population of Australia travels
in our uh wagons in our Railway wagons
on our trains and we have set ourselves
the target to achieve Net Zero for our
Railways we have also set our sales
targets for solar energy for ethanol 10
mix of ethanol we have completed this
target before this set date we are also
working in the area of green hydrogen we
want India to be a green hydrogen Hub
and we are working towards this
uh in the international
solar Alliance has been launched by
India in many countries have joined it
and are working with India the island
countries we have helped them in the
area of solar energy so that they have
now got a new confidence that we are
with them in their efforts to fight
climate change and we will not only
fulfill our responsibilities but we will
also help you in the area of climate
change we have seen that due to natural
calamities
people talk about the death of people no
doubt when there are natural disasters
but there is a lot of destruction of
infrastructure as well and therefore
because of climate change the kind of
Crisis we are feeling we need to develop
infrastructure that is resilient and
therefore we have created a global
organization called cdri and you perhaps
know that in Glasgow I presented a
subject to the world and recently it was
launched by the U.N Secretary General
and myself that is mission life and when
I say life I mean lifestyle for the
environment therefore every individual
you must live his life in a
pro-environment a pro-development way
and we are working towards this and I am
sure that
whatever a work India has started in all
these areas not because India has
adversely affected the environment of
the world we are doing this because we
have a concern for future Generations we
do not want to give our future
Generations a world that make life
difficult for them and therefore as a
global responsibility India has not
caused any problems to the environment
however we are playing a leading role in
contributing in a positive manner as far
as prosperous countries are concerned
there's always been talk about
technology transfer financial support
and
there are some countries that need to
have technology transfer financial
support and we hope that as soon as we
can move forward in this area we will be
able to solve this challenge of climate
change thank you very much
we have caused damage in the United
States the way we developed over the
last 300 years
and that's why I was able to convince my
colleague into Congress to pass the
decision
the largest climate fund ever in America
in the world history
369 billion dollars 369 billion dollars
to deal with the climate crisis and we
are doing it extensively now and I think
you're going to see significant progress
thank you all very very much
well that was Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi and U.S President Joe
Biden speaking at the White House where
Modi is enjoying a full State visit they
both declared that the U.S India
partnership is stronger closer and more
Dynamic than at any time in history and
Biden even declared that our economic
relationship is booming they also
addressed some of the criticisms of
modi's government saying that press
Freedom religious freedom is vital to
the success of democracies and Modi even
declared that there is no place for
discrimination in India well we're going
to go to our White House correspondent
Kimberly halket who joins us now and
they really were both of them talking up
the economic benefits of their
relationship here weren't they
yeah there's no question that that has
been a significant part of this visit
they're looking to each other to really
kind of underscore the value of this
relationship and expand on that there
are a number of agreements that are
being signed as well as announced in
this visit an expansion of the trade and
defense partnership in fact we know that
there is going to be an investment of
some 2 billion in terms of Indian
companies investing in the United States
in terms of the defense partnership that
is being announced and that expansion is
really something that is going to be
underscored in the Investments that are
being made it's going to be a new
chapter in the defense industry that was
announced just by the Indian Prime
Minister and the reason for this is that
the both leaders see the success of this
partnership as being something that's
not just good for the United States and
India but they believe for the rest of
the world and so this is going to open
up jobs they believe but also it's going
to really benefit the global economy and
so they talked about this and and this
being something that will be useful for
their Nations but also they talked about
how the partnership will be useful for
diplomacy on other areas in the world
stage namely Ukraine you heard there the
Indian Prime Minister talking about how
he believes that the resolution there
will come through dialogue and diplomacy
and this is important because the U.S
president believing that well we have
seen some abstaining by India at the
United Nations when it comes to coming
down hard on Russia that there may be
some movement in that area by India in
the future and so that is a focus at the
uh of discussion in the Oval Office we
understand now now there was a bit of
news there as well with some of the
questions that came from reporters
significant was the fact that there was
a question there about some of the
comments that the U.S president made
calling president XI of China a dictator
uh something that he said in front of
donors in recent days this is
significant because of course this came
just out on the heels of his own
Secretary of State going to try and ease
tensions
in China in Beijing and this is
something that the U.S president was
asked about and he said that it's a fact
and he says that he does look forward to
meeting Xi Jinping in the future so this
is a little bit of news coming out of
there he says he doesn't regret calling
Xi Jinping a dictator and as well there
was a little bit of a discussion as well
uh the U.S president talking about the
importance of religious pluralism and
then and Narendra Modi the Indian leader
responding there with regard to the his
Crackdown on religious minorities namely
Muslims in his country really denying
some of the accusations that have been
leveled against him and saying that he
Embraces religious pluralism something
that the U.S president has also been
pushing to underscore so the news and
the headlines coming out of that really
some of the challenges that the U.S
president has had to face with regard to
some of his own comments and of course
also some of the uh challenges that the
U.S rather the Indian leader has had to
face and will be facing as he goes now
to the U.S Congress where he will be
making a joint address the fact that
many uh or at least a handful of leaders
in the US Congress will be boycotting
that speech given again some of his own
some of their concerns with regard to
the human rights allegations against him
the continue to creep up in this visit
okay thank you so much that is Kimberly
hellkit our White House correspondent